اه يا دودي تذكاريه كثيره ازيلت بعد عام
2003 وبنا تراثيه فقدت هويتها البصريه
بسبب عمليات تاهيل وترميم لكن الحكايه لم
تنتهي هنا في بغداد تشوه كل يوم النصب
التذكاريه والفنيه تعالوا معي قليلا نعوذ
بالزمان لنعرف كيف حصل ذلك
[موسيقى]
صباح
الجمال اه
[موسيقى]
العباسيه ابو نقاس تمثال يطل على نهر دجله
ويتصدر شارعا سمي باسمه انه واحد من روائع
النحات العراقي اسماعيل فتاح التركي كتب
على قاعده التمثال ابيات من شعره لكنها
ازيلت بعمليه تخريبيه في عام 2015 ثم بترت
اصابع التمثال في عام 2018
ربما التمثال بعد الحادثتين لكن الفاعل
بقي مجهوله
[موسيقى]
من من رح
يم وفي عام 20022 يتعرضوا تمثال كهرمانه
الشهير الى حادث سير اسفر عن مقتل ثلاثه
من الاربعين لصا المتواجدين داخل هذه
الجرار الامر الذي اثار سخريه على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي
[موسيقى]
سال المسمى بنصب انقاذ الثقافه وهو للنحات
العراقي محمد غني حكمت فينتهك كل يوم
تقريبا ويشوه بعبارات تسيء الى العباره
المسماريه التي كتبها حكمت والتي تقول هنا
بدات الكتابه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تفرضوا الماده
477 من قانون العقوبات العراقيه عقوبه
الحبسي لكل من خرب او اتلف نصبا او شاهدا
في ساحه عامه كما تعمل الجهات المعنيه على
معالجه هذا التخريب بشكل دائم لكن التشويه
مستمر للعاصمه بطرق وذراعه مختلفه زينب
المشهد صباح العربيه بغداد
[موسيقى]